[Music]
in foreveralone news submitted by marry
me taiga know what the [ __ ] holds that
kid you [ __ ] pervert get the [ __ ] out
here oh sorry rich is this person yeah
do you have a gallery a significant
dowry yeah maybe ask the right questions
a survey sheds light on why you might be
struggling to find a partner that is so
funny number one you're ugly there's a
basic [ __ ] number two you're kind of
weird
you always have AI burgers this also
goes for the bristles though you know
the ones that are out there on Twitter
that are like I trust no man tried that
like your Pickers off there's a lot of
that [ __ ] on Twitter man so much a lot
of like like man Haiti [ __ ] lately dude
I feel bad on Twitter dude I just go on
and they're like when men do you need to
get yourself a real man it does this
disappear [ __ ] oh my gosh she's 12
years old you're trying to back off but
then you end it with a [ __ ] yeah I have
to [ __ ] cut bag no because I follow
some fans you know just says you know
they can you follow me oh why not
and they'll retweet stuff and that's how
I see all the funny weird [ __ ] I know
why not I'm not in the in the end that's
why not so like the other day I saw a
video of a lady taking a shot out of a
guy's uncircumcised dick what so he had
his sports can he pulled it out somebody
poured a shot inside and it'll suck the
shot oh you know I thought you dis no no
no no a little shot out of a pulled out
foreskin dance wait do they pull it up
like this that hurt but I looked at it I
couldn't figure out what it was like
what did I just watch what is it again
and I was like I was at like a bar
restaurant thing with Nicki one time and
the owner of the other place me and Iggy
were kind of sitting like across from
each other cuz we were their parents so
it was like she was like diagonal for me
and then I was with across from her dad
and her mom drew here and so the owner
comes up to Nicky and he's like like
he's like okay everybody we're gonna do
a [ __ ] shot yeah and then he grabs
Nicky he's like come on and on my and he
gets up on the bar and he's like [ __ ]
like sitting on the edge of the bar and
put in pouring the shot like in his own
yeah for Nicky to come take well Nicky
was like she was like you know she's the
people pleasers she was kind of getting
taken with it it was pretty weird
yeah her dad was this kind of war her
dad was kind of watching the game so he
was pretty absorbed I was like okay what
if he's like no you're not bro all right
but then he disappointedly had to watch
me get the [ __ ] you like stopped her
right oh I'm sorry he grabs your head
like no no yes yes yes yeah it's how you
do a [ __ ]
drop me Nicky there is this poll that
was conducted by an online medical
service called body logic MD in it
asthma 1,300 single adults about why
they're still single
cuz I love being single dude it's a toy
you're gonna ask the single people what
they love about being sick they're
asking like why are you still single
that's the Saturday 65 percent said that
they blame themselves for the reason
that's why they're single oh wow
damn that's pretty adult so it falls
under things like they don't like they
feel like they're too fat or that they
don't have a chiseled abs or because
they're too sexually conservative or
they're too boring or they're too nerdy
or they're too bold or they're too
risk-averse
does all that [ __ ] like all pretty much
they're just saying that they have like
low self-esteem
that's the reason why they're single
because they have low self-esteem yeah
it's not that [ __ ] not Magnon cheese
labs because I already checked like 80%
of that list so and I still got married
yourself just let you know self
confidence abuser chiseled abs you can't
get checked yep you're kidding me no
like if you're weird enough to do it an
easy destroying piece yeah yeah yeah
yeah or if you're - like I I'm super
inspired and I read a lot of self-help
books on tics like yeah it's a freak
freak out territory oh how to please you
I read it in the book what I know about
the [ __ ] is funny and crazy things to
you in bed this is my anatomy book
everywhere he's actually blowing off his
dick actually pretty much I've had
somebody say to me before like literally
it was like we're having dinner second
time hanging out they're like talking
out something like an ex-girlfriend
right right he was like yeah he was like
I didn't get anything from that
relationship well except I learned that
the structure of my penis is perfect for
hitting the g-spot so his dick like
curves up this he's got the perfect day
and like also I'm so caught off guard
because like I'm new to LA yeah yeah
yeah did you spit out your food dude no
I like this we like oh did you even for
one second go like I have to try it cuz
that's what he thinks or I'm gonna look
at him and be like well we'll see about
that challenge accepted that's what he
was like I got the perfect
so they like based on the conversation
prior I knew I couldn't laugh at him
about it and I still remember when he
dropped me off in my house he dropped me
off like this
this is where the man here Twitter
people come from yes guys like this to
meet them guys like this yeah and I like
manners nothing sucks I guess guys like
that do exist
oh no they're very they're very brutal
very I remember reading something about
this one dude once that he is lying for
girls it's like to tell them that he's a
virgin and apparently it works that a
lot of these women are like I'm gonna be
your first oh my gosh she'll teach you
these things and all this [ __ ] and I'm
like damn girls are really that dumb
well but some of those guys they would
prey on a specific type of woman so that
exact type of woman she wants to like
feel important and feel validated and it
take a guy's virginity is like you know
important no that would be the one that
would be down for the curve dick oh
that's why he presents it like that
I want the [ __ ] yeah I guess so yeah
that's not really like a date you know
Wilson we gotta hook up at the end I
thought it was like a business meeting I
thought that like I thought we were just
like networking no it was not a date
date when he dropped you off you said
yeah yeah I don't have a car so he like
just picked me up and was like oh we're
gonna go down the shooter bit of room
who doesn't know she's on date she's on
date it was somebody guy I met through
work oh yeah you met him at full screen
or something and he's like let's go get
drinks tonight and I'll get you dinner
and you're like okay cool it's just a
work meeting you don't know this person
then you hopped in a car with them this
was somebody that I met
the sphere of my job and like the whole
preference : did you know him for well
also somebody else was supposed to come
to dinner with us and they fell and they
dropped off okay okay that's better just
move on there cuz I was thinking like
damn this guy's been planning it for a
while maybe I don't know I don't know
but yeah I normally would my thing is
like I'm not gonna be in a situation
that seems like a date because I don't
wanna give him anything wrong like what
do you did was talk about that homie hey
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of both
with my curb big and then homie was like
that's a good lie boys like you're
talking about bows bows with the amazing
Mets with this cat said after he said
other than finding out my penis is
stressfully perfect to hit the g-spot
was he like so something like kind of
shock you like that happens and you just
kind of black out like my brain goes
through like a roadmap of responses I
have like a PR roadmap in here and I'm
like what do we do I would have been
like oh dude why are you telling me that
I think I said something like wow so I
was like so that relationship didn't
work out why not so like I what I went
like you know that's a line that
somebody says in a movie right good
social Jesus says it though for some
reason the whole restaurant went quiet
and the whole restaurant heard drop in
class that's it keep spilling the water
all the [ __ ] bad date and enjoy
Roberts movie right like he's like he's
like tell me tell me I don't know yes
about that my I have a curved piece of
this made for the Whoopie nose deep
sorry this date is over great speed I
want to try it
that was amazing yeah wait you guys have
never been in like a weird thing like
that where somebody said something just
like I don't really date did you know
that my tongue is perfectly fitted for a
vagina like it's like a
that's like all the dudes I knew in San
Diego they talk like that it's like
you're just sitting at dinner he looks
like I didn't like the deterring kind
gets quiet he's like so have you
considered that my tongue is perfect for
your vagina I know that I could eat
[ __ ] and breathe through my nose like
here like so did you no thank you doing
that it's really [ __ ] me up because I
said yeah you know something about
sitting up perfectly straight while
saying that - yeah I can eat perfect
[ __ ] I'm gonna grow up and dine out
good like I didn't like it wouldn't have
like I'm very much like if somebody
wants to shoot their shot shoot you shot
at like go ahead and then I'll you know
carry on you know whatever but they had
that was a lot so what did it feel like
when you [ __ ] them no work okay my bad
was he attractive initially and then and
he blew it I was never attracted also
like let me say this was my first time
going to dinner with anyone in Los
Angeles
oh look wise out of 1 to 10 what did he
look like four and a half oh [ __ ] that's
mad low Wow an LA four and a half is
love
[Music]